y'a pas un appareil électronique dans le
monde soit un téléphone portable l'ipad
qui a pas un élément brevetée par hydro
québec
c'est un secret trop bien gardé
hydro-québec fait de la recherche dans
les batteries depuis 1967 et dans celle
au lithium depuis 1979
karim zaghib est à la tête du centre
d'excellence en électrification des
transports et en stockage d'énergie
d'hydro-québec à varennes un centre de
recherche unique au monde qui compte une
centaine de chercheurs depuis que cet
électron chimiste originaire d'algérie a
souffert d'une crise d'asthme dans un
embouteillage quand il était jeune il
s'est juré de tout faire pour qu'un jour
tous les transports soit électrique
formé en france et au japon il travaille
sur des batteries depuis 25 ans au
centre d'excellence c'est important son
nom est associé à plus de 550 brevets
aujourd'hui les batteries sont au
lithium millions dans une batterie et la
note qui le graphite
une cathode la majorité c'est du nickel
cobalt manganèse et un séparateur il ya
7000 batterie semblables dans une tesla
par contre une nissan leaf aura 200
batteries plates comme celle ci moins
encombrante les deux contiennent un
séparateur un électrolyte liquide qui
est inflammable gros inconvénient à
l'heure actuelle on a développé une
technologie lithium-ion est sécuritaire
donc on travaille maintenant sur la
patrie sous solide
la difficulté était de maîtriser le
laminage du lithium
c'est fait le fait qu'on a 25 ans
d'expérience en nitrates mans lissalde
ferment actuellement la batterie tout
solide fonctionne à une haute
température de 80 degrés celsius on
cherche à l'abaisser à une température
ambiante
on cherche aussi à réduire le coût et à
augmenter la capacité des batteries
au niveau de l'autonomie on vise minimum
800 km le plus important c'est le prix
dans la batterie tout solide à partir de
2025 2026 la voiture électrique l'un va
être pratiquement au même prix qu'une
voiture à essence
karim zaghib est déjà reconnue par la
communauté scientifique internationale
le prix lionel boulet qu'il vient de
recevoir et la consécration de ce
chercheur ici au québec
un prix qui me touche beaucoup c'est un
prix que c'est un prix de groupe aussi
donc c'est pas juste pour moi donc moi
j'ai d'excellentes dijon qui travaillent
dans l'ombre ou sinon quand c'est un
prix qui appartient à man group
bonjour ça va bien maintenant karim
zaghib soutient que tout peut se faire
ici et qu'il suffit de s'y mettre
on devrait en prendre un exemple sur
l'aéronautique et avoir une intégration
avec un écosystème dont le noyau
hydro-québec à sa technologie
le gouvernement il est là pour aider les
investisseurs et les mines
un consortium en mettant aussi les
universités instituts de recherche
ensemble
[Musique]